a subway construction project in Los
Angeles is unearthing the prehistoric
side of Southern California workers
evacuating the tunnels discovered
fossils of ancient mammals that roam the
area about 11,000 years ago the historic
tro includes bones from extinct beasts
like mammoths and mastodons Carter
Edmonds went underneath Los Angeles to
see how building buildings future is
shedding new light on the past
underneath one of the busiest parts of
the city one of the largest subway
projects in the country is under
construction
it was here workers digging the new line
literally made a mammoth discovery alien
Tala gist dr. Ashley Leger
oversees a team which works alongside
construction crews searching for fossils
their discoveries began with bones of
Colombian mammoths who roamed here in
herds during the Ice Age first came this
three-foot section of tusk that's at
least 11,000 years old then this nearly
complete skull emerged a rare find so
what does it mean that this one is
pretty much intact a dream come true for
a paleontologist this is the the bucket
list you always want to find at some
point in your career and then it's one
of the first things we found here this
is probably the best gig in town for
paleontologist Dave Sottero is with LA
Metro which hired the experts who dug up
the past it's not every day you have a
subway project going through a rich
fossil area so it's tremendously
exciting for everybody on the project
this is a vertebra this is a vertebra
from a bison over the next few weeks the
tunnel will close in on an ancient area
known as the La Brea Tar Pits about a
mile away Leger expects the fossil finds
will increase dramatically in that area
just a couple of inches of tar became a
sticky deathtrap for the massive mammals
that roamed here tens of thousands of
years ago when most people think of Los
Angeles they think of Hollywood Beverly
Hills what do you think of you know I
think of what's under all of that under
everyone's feet
this rich history that everybody misses
so we get to open up people's eyes open
up their imagination and bring the past
to life
prehistoric black ooze still seeps from
the ground around the museum which
contains the world's largest collection
of Ice Age fossils here at the Museum
all of these things come to life they
stand up in front of you they kind of
speak to that curiosity that we're all
born with you're going to be digging
through that stuff that is bubbling up
through the ground right around here yes
we're gonna be sticky and dirty and
we're gonna love every second of it
so this is behind the scenes this is
where the magic happens and where the
researchers come almost every bone ever
found near the Tar Pits is kept here
cataloged for further research they
helped Pledger identify one of her
newest finds so we can confirm that it
is a horse astragalus or the ankle bone
back in the tunnel more clues about the
ancient past keep turning up a leg bone
from an extinct camel and a tooth from a
mastodon
[Music]
and according to legend the best is yet
to come in the next few weeks she hopes
to add more predators like the
saber-tooth cat to her finds if you're
keeping score we have found two mammoths
a mastodon a camel a bison horse and a
turtle and you're just getting started
we're just getting started
for CBS this morning Carter Evans Los
Angeles if you're keeping score yes you
know I think dr. Ashley ledger should be
more enthusiastic about it she loves it
low back woozy sticky stuff sound like
fun dr. ledger absolutely that is very
cool stuff